metropolitan police this lunch time who
tell us
that a post-mortem examination into the
death
of sarah everard has been held
it has concluded the cause of death was
compression to the neck you'll remember
that
this marketing manager sarah was 33 she
disappeared
in south london while walking home from
a friend's house
on march the 3rd and her body was found
later
in woodland in kent serving police
officer wayne cousins has been remanded
in custody
charged with her murder so that is in
from
scotland yard that the cause of sarah
everard's death was compression
to the neck metropolitan police just
confirming that
in the past few minutes at a post-mortem
examination which has now proved of
course conclusive